this is not how or when they wanted it
to end
England checking out of Qatar still
pained by the quarter-final defeat to
France and in the bid for World Cup
Glory
the morning after thank you I appreciate
it
what was it like to actually get the
chance to speak to Drew Bellingham like
I'm a bit gobsmacked to be honest and I
wasn't sure how close we'd be able to
get uh we just wanted to come down and
just to wave the flag one more time and
say like you can hold your heads up high
you did England proud
Captain Harry Kane assumed
responsibility tweeting of his hurt
after the penalty Mr allowed France to
go through with a 2-1 Victory England
players aren't used to leaving
tournaments this early anymore having
reached the semi-finals the 2018 World
Cup and the Euro 2020 final after such
an agonizing exit the Three Lions
players will have to watch the final
week of this world cup from afar escara
Southgate deliberates on his future
after six years in charge and whether to
lead England into Euro 2024 qualifying
whenever I've finished these tournaments
I've needed time to make
correct decisions because emotionally
you go through
so many different feelings and
the energy that it takes
um
through these tournaments is enormous so
I I want to make the right decision
he's still under contract and the fa say
they've been incredibly proud of the
manager and his players at the World Cup
England and Southgate have time with the
next games not until March
three tournaments for five years is a
lot with England you know what I mean
it'll be a lot for a manager to sort of
cope with and what what he has to go
through all the time but I think that
one more tournament would feel right to
me but if he does say that he's not
going to continue to the next tournament
I would like to think that he could stay
within the fa looking at the sort of
Designing of the sort of future for the
English to make sure the next 10 years
can continue with the success with the
men's and women's game because I think
we're in a pretty good place
England returning home not in a
particularly bad place or facing a
clamor for change but a decision for
Southgate and where the change might be
better for him and England as the weight
goes on to fly back from a tournament
with a trophy Rob Harris Sky News
alwacra in Qatar